were you ever embarrassed by your
parents and by yeah because because I
would think and I know you probably feel
guilty about this now and I said but you
do right because you don't when you when
you're a kid and you don't fit in and
your parents don't speak English it's a
tremendous shame right horrible your
name is funny I mean nowadays I think
the way that I look people are like oh
she just looks just brown hair it's not
that weird when I came to America in 91
I was ethnic and to me I was like what
was like it was just everything about me
stood out I didn't speak the language I
wasn't blonde in blue eyes I didn't eat
peanut butter and jelly sandwiches I you
know it's like a very weird thing where
I went to school in a uniform yeah in
Russia everybody wore like it maybe was
communism so everybody worked very much
like a brown little thing with you know
so you show up and you're the kid in
school with the uniform on and
everybody's wearing you know their their
sneakers in there and I didn't know what
jeans were I mean like it's like simple
you know elements of life that you're
like how do you not know what jeans are
I didn't know what jeans were here and
you at nine years old you announced I
want to take an acting class yes which
was expensive it was pricey was at six
nine hundred dollars something like that
I always thought it was like two hundred
and fifty dollars and my parents had
like nine hundred dollars in the bank
account and we were doing my mom and I
were doing this interview and not that
long ago I learned that it was eight
hundred and ninety dollars and we had
nine hundred dollars in the bank account
you know most parents would have said
you know what we don't have any money we
got nine hundred dollars and you're
gonna take up all our savings and
there's no way we're gonna TP it or
something and learn how to act there
there's absolutely no rhyme or reason
for what my mom did and why she did it
mind you I never got birthday presents
never got holiday gifts like we weren't
a family of givers in that regard
right so the fact that my mom was like
writing this I mean it it's one of those
kismet moments that you can't explain so
wait let me get this straight so you
take some acting classes I don't know
how long this goes and then you said hey
I'm gonna go out on an audition your mom
takes you to the audition No
so here's what happened this story gets
weirder okay okay so I so I went to a
place called Beverly Hill studios total
ripoff it a hundred percent it was like
every kid got accepted so long as you
had the money to pay he's one of those
will run and it was like five six hours
on a Saturday and you kind of just go
there and you really don't do anything
they pretend you pretend right so my
manager Susan Curtis
who's still my manager to this day some
almost 33 and I signed with her when I
was nine how do you get a manager when
you're nine because I'm sure there's
lots of little kids out there that would
want to be doing what you're doing this
is all called being the right place the
right time did she manage just all
different types of people it was a game
mostly kids yeah and she was driving by
and saw a bunch of kids standing outside
and she's like oh what's this place
literally I'm Beverly Drive pulled over
walked in and they're like we're doing a
showcase with children she goes oh weird
I'm a manager and they were like come on
in that's how great this place was but
my parents told me to decide and that's
the crazy part is they were like go meet
with whoever you know responded to you
as 9:00 and then they're like you make a
decision you want to do this be
responsible your parents which I really
do applaud they never took a dime from
you never which is unusual when you
think about their economic situation we
were really poor and I had money yeah
here's the crazy thing about all this
but nine when I I got the first
commercial went out for it was like
camping Barbie or something you actually
camping Barbie was one those girls that
you know those old-school Mattel
commercials where you play with the
Barbie and you're like wow that was me
you did a couple of like TV shots on
Days of Our Lives you did Baywatch don't
just read it my Days of Our Lives ago
I'm not I think that's great did you
have a lot of lines so you went from it
was my first kiss how old were you on
days of our lives
probably like 9 or 10 and you had a kiss
from who this really sweet boy that I
ended up like hanging out with later in
life we ran into each other and I was
like oh my god you were my first kiss I
had to kiss him on the cheek and I I
wasn't I was mortified
and did you discuss it with your mom you
were like hey I don't know now I think
my mom was like I can't even
she couldn't even wrap her head around
it my mom my dad worked full time the
entire would you have blamed your
parents if they had taken some money
from you and said hey look we invested
in your acting class what I mean it's
really noble of them that they were
broken they didn't say to you look
you're making some money here you had
sort of a hefty bank account at that
point I did yeah I would never blame
them I've never been able to pay for
dinner like to this day I've never like
I I'll be like let's go out to dinner
for your birthday dad and then like he
calls the restaurant before we get there
and put this card down and I'm like I
don't
like I'm a grown-ass woman like I would
love to treat you and mommy to something
and they're like no they won't let you
spoil them at all this has been a huge
never what if you said to them I want to
help you with a new house or something I
want you to Howard nothing I cannot
stress to you how stubborn they are Wow
and they're by the way they're gonna be
listening to this going that's right